My name is Morgan Freeman.
I'm going to do a dramatic reading from a very popular songwriter.
For all the times that you rain on my parade,...
...and all the clubs you get in using my name.
You think you broke my heart?
Oh girl, for goodness' sake.
You think I'm crying on my own?
Well, I ain't.
And I didn't wanna write a song 'cause I didn't want anyone thinking I still care.
I don't.
But, you still hit my phone up.
And baby I'm moving on.
And I think you should be something I don't wanna hold back.
Maybe you should know that.
My mama didn't like you and she likes everyone.
And I never liked to admit that I was wrong.
And I've been so caught up in my job,...
...didn't see what was going on.
But now, I know.
I'm better sleeping on my own.
'Cause if you like the way you look that much,...
...oh baby, you should go and love yourself.
And if you think that I'm still holding on to something,...
...you should go and love yourself.